-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
Well, it's Wednesday,
so it's time for Donald Trump's
crime of the week.
What is it this week?
Did he tie a lady
to some train tracks?
Did he blow up city hall?
Oh, massive tax fraud,
the old classic.
[ Laughter ]
New York attorney general
Letitia James today
filed an over-200-page
civil fraud lawsuit
against former president Trump,
several of his children,
business partners
in The Trump Organization.
I'd say he needs a good lawyer,
but that's been true
for a while now.
[ Laughter ]
In the new lawsuit filed today,
New York attorney general
Letitia James
alleges that
The Trump Organization
deceived lenders, insurers,
and tax officials
by inflating the value
of its properties.
Even worse, he listed himself
as 6'7" on his Tinder profile.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
hosted a reception today
at New York's American Museum
of Natural History,
where he also spent some time
catching up with old friends.
"Chompy!"
[ Laughter ]
"It's been ages, Chompy.
Ohh! Oh, God, no, Chompy."
[ Laughter ]
"What did they do to you,
Chompy?"
[ Laughter ]
Russia announced plans
to hold an annexation vote
in occupied portions of Ukraine.
And this is cool --
They also announced
what the results
of the vote will be.
[ Laughter ]
You don't have to stay up late.
According to the latest numbers,
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg's
net worth
decreased this year
by more than $71 billion.
No wonder he wants to live
in the metaverse.
He can't afford a place
in San Francisco anymore.
[ Laughter ]
The 22nd annual
Congressional Basketball Game
was held on Monday night,
and the team of Congress people
beat the team of lobbyists.
Or -- just throwing this
out there -- they let you win.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Kentucky recently
set a Guinness world record
after driving a mile in reverse
in just over 75 seconds.
He then smartly refused
the breathalyzer.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, what?
I set a world record?
Alright!"
According to new survey,
3% of Americans
said that they have waited
in a line for over eight hours.
"Well, we're still not opening
a second register,"
said CVS.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, officials
from the CDC said this week
that there was a 26% rise
in syphilis infections
reported last year.
Well, good luck with that.
We couldn't even get people
to wear masks.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.